we have a voicemail number that number
is
2192 David P here's a caller who wants
some clarity on Yiddish and Jewish words
so of course when people need Clarity on
that I guess they call me
hi David uh I'm from Alabama okay and
this is a genuine question uh I just
don't meet many Jewish people so pardon
my ignorance but I hear the term
schmickel sometimes and
does that mean penis or money okay and
I'm not trolling here I'm seriously
asking because sometimes I hear in the
context of
okay they're definitely talking about
their
phallic region but um I just don't know
man okay so here's the deal there's two
similar sounding words the words are
schmeckle and shekel okay schmeckle
means little penis in Yiddish schmeckle
shekel means money shekels were silver
coins used in ancient Israel and the
Middle East it's now the currency of
Israel the new Israeli shekel the latter
shekel is sometimes used
anti-semitically so for example I'm
Gonna Get You have to these are often
dog whistles so you have to understand
the context when you see like these
right Wingers go
you know all of these heads of media
outlets and film studios hoarding their
shekels when they say that they're
saying these Jewish CEOs hoarding money
so sometimes shekel is used as a dog
whistle it is the new Israeli shekel the
current currency in the uh state of
Israel all right so hopefully that is uh
Illuminating on the bonus show today are
there going to be presidential debates
in 2024 maybe not and we'll tell you why
there's an Austin Texas basic income
program that's going to give struggling
residents a thousand dollars a month and
there are concerns about Senator Dianne
Feinstein I'll tell you what those
concerns are all of those stories and
more on today's bonus show sign up at
joinpakman.com to get instant access I
will see you then